vous écoutez bien ce tour pour une vidéo
extrêmement spéciale avec un parler ça
fait mourir de rire
comme vous avez dit un soir de la sortie
vidéo sbk rouge tous les deux leurs
agents et et a pris s'est passé de très
longues histoires speaker avant vouloir
mais je suis obligée vous raconter c'est
trop drôle à temps parce qu'un enfant
derrière d'enfants on a 12 ans s'amuse
avec une couette et du papier qu aulas
aux arêtes et ça y est souvent 8h30 mais
parce que ça s'arrête pas du tout
l'amitié avec son bandeau sur les yeux
me faisait penser à quel chien personnes
mortal kombat là qu'il ya une épée de
tous et du coup je me suis dit qu'on
allait faire un verre sur mortal kombat
bon c'est quoi un verre dans cinq mois
mais là les choses doivent se régler et
déjà faire et je gueule mais je mets la
pâte pour faire une vidéo c'est juste
pour le fun voici sous vos yeux ébahis
le duel catchy face à conques jean
on se souvient de la vidéo sur mortal
kombat est obligé de travail parce qu'il
sait que je me calme à tous les jeux
sauf à celui-là est à fifa parce que cet
homme connaît même pas les combos donc
ça va être un gars des organes comme il
fait ça la gâchette sa gâchette
regardez regardez tu perds des gaules
ohada
mais t'es sérieux comme eux j'ai gagné
premiers ont gagné alors j'ai jamais
joué à awarta convaincu teint ne tient
pas fait car non non j'en ai fait aucune
soit fermé qu'à court pas mal c'est que
ça mélange intéressant alors déjà mais
[ __ ] c'est quoi pourquoi ignorer
pourquoi tu rajoutes américain on
connaît tous cette fête est à zoug qui
va du cardage vient là mais attends via
la bombe et à l'abattoir une musique via
rail à la 4' la viande concours vient
bien la chute montrer comment à tort qu
allah et la diction fatalité au regard
des mechas n'est pas égal à sa grande
surprise j'ai gagné tout ce que j'ai
torché le jeu pour tramway lui qui a
très peu joué
du coup je me dis allez jeu
poser un duel sur son jeu de
prédilection c'est un bâtard mois sur
l'a4 à l'est et c'est là c'est là
mesdames et messieurs c'est
extraordinaire ce week end jean pellez
parce qu'il a perdu c'est mortal kombat
mais ça va continuer regardez le match
je me met en vedette naomi cas là c'est
un jeu de prédilection c'est le mec
c'est bien un nouveau trailer du monde
attend par contre si je te passe sur le
casting mon gars je jouis non désolé
désolé c'est nul je fais télé parce que
je t'aime beaucoup à [ __ ] un patois
par toi partout and away we sing
d'arrêter je vais arrêter là car
d'ailleurs un petit faisait le malin non
désolé bros lucas il transmet regarder
le même design du try hard n'a pas du
tout mais très à mon gamin
ohlala oh la la c'est quoi jeter par le
visage à la barre du micro mais c'était
nul regagna quoi de bien assis toi
jamais été aussi bois rouge est d'y
aller moi j'étais mort
mais oui non oui oh oui oh oui les rages
et rabat en revanche n'ont pas eu mal à
la vague écolo allez merci d'avancé
l'udc n'a pas marché auquel on
recommence extraordinaire victoire du
chien et l'amica sur l'ultimatum du
large qui vient de tout perdre
alors on se lie à tout gagner m'a marqué
c'est toujours ça on va donner ses cours
il est entraîneur il ya toujours ceux
qui gagnent la dernière vient en outre
est donc le seul à ne pas faire trop
trop tu me donnes sort deux derniers
matches sylvain picard et devrait
attendre ce feu sacré coeur ainsi
franchir le mal qu'il en est là il a pu
faire tout est ok je vraiment j'aurais
beau titre en jeu sur un chiffon mis au
banc en bois ou en 3g fou mais c'est
faux mais j'ai beau mais c'est une femme
apte à tenir bien pour moi c'est faux
mais j'ai paumé g22 de ma façon on est
d'accord g/km sur kate moss où l on y va
c'est vrai chiffre à l'otan attends je
me sens qu'est ce que tu as fait perdre
et 6 ou enquête et fait 1 2 3 chi tam et
qui s'enflamment et trois deux un
chiffon me on lui a fait plaisir on les
a faites il ya surtout pierre festival
basé sur la short qu'il est très content
donc là on fait l'outro de la vidéo vous
avez vu hier
pour ça qui fait une danse de la joie
derrière moi peur chez nous trop et
qu'ils ont fait un doigt ou je veux dire
au revoir et sa salle palas et l'accès
vraiment louis sims c'est après avoir
fini la vidéo et cetera on aller dans le
salon et je vais proposer un petit fifa
mikail bas tous les jeux sauf à cela et
à fifa voilà on a fait un match plein
juste après tournage de la vidéo que
vous êtes en train de mois aux quatre
minutes de jaya zhao plus tôt le matin
mika me fait pas de fautes notamment que
mes joueurs meurt dans ce match bonjour
fait tout simplement un salto avant
s'acharne sur mika messi est blessé
ils veulent sans fin du match
vos gros journée pour mika l'eau qui
vient de perdre son portail combat pur 4
ligue puis giffa 2 0 est obligé fou et
chifoumi il a gagné je pense qu'en
rentrant chez lui va se faire écraser
dans l'essai sur le make a vraiment pas
de charge aujourd'hui comme mika en
position foetale latéral j'arrête les
jeux vidéo macquarie boulanger j'en ai
marre des jeux on espère que tu vas tu
améliorée sur le jeu vidéo puisque là
c'est pas trop ça en fait attend mon
chèque pour bomber allégeance et bientôt
si dieu j'espère que vous appelez ce cas
n'hésitez pas à lui et que d'habitude je
voulais vraiment partager avec vous ce
grand moment parce que franchement ça
fait surface plus de trois ans je
connais me car ce n'était jamais arrivé
que je batte sur autant de jeux
d'affilée et sur son lieu de
prédilection personnes ont regardé en
s'entraînant dans une prochaine vidéo
portez vous bien au revoir les cadrages
l'afp